can say it to him all I want but again  as a man he has to believe in himself I  can't believe that a guy would leave a  full-blown marriage just because he  doesn't think he's financially safe  you're already married no it's not even  that it's not even that it's men also  overthink what we like the way we  overthink things have you have you ever  have you ever called him like God on  your knees begged and apologized got on  your knees and said I was wrong like you  were right  yeah we've had conversations we've had  conversations for sure he's not yeah  I've apologize and he's apologized and  we both agreed that when he is it's more  he needs to be but he needs to accept  where he is in his life and I can't  impose for example I think a man when he  knows he's got a responsibility  especially a father a child and a woman  he wants to now make sure he's got  enough money to support and again his  dreams his dreams